well I live in Sherwood which is about
five minutes up the road from magdala
road which was one of the roads that we
found that was cordoned off this morning
and I remember going to bed last night
and I had the decision of whether or not
I leave my window open and I did and it
must have been about 20 past five this
morning I just heard siren after siren
after siren it was just like there was a
barrage of vehicles heading towards that
area and um it lasted about half an hour
to 40 minutes I would say and I actually
messaged my girlfriend about 6am and
said something big is happening around
here because I've never heard anything
like it in terms of the um the response
of the emergency services and then of
course you know waking up this morning
we hear that the um the tram Network had
suspended all services buses were being
diverted and we were told to avoid the
city center and everyone's been you know
waiting for this news to emerge to find
out what's happened and of course the
news did come out and from
Nottinghamshire police and it's it's
just caused Devastation I it's the only
way that I can describe it my heart is
still racing from something that I found
out about you know over an hour ago it's
not in such a supportive close-knit
Community it's
it's just rattled the city it's it's
it's shocking it really is shocking
um you heard all the sirens go by so it
was the it was the cacophony I'm
guessing the number of sirens at first
alerted you to the fact that something
big was happening yeah it was exactly
that I I knew something wasn't right you
just there was something about it that
just gave me that feeling of this is not
right there's something you know bad
happening here and of course we know now
that this wasn't an isolated incident
you look at all the streets that have
been cordoned off across the city and
let's not forget you know Nottingham
isn't a massive City it's it's it's
quite small when you actually get into
the city center and this has affected
various different locations which has
really affected things
um this morning and it yeah as I say
it's there's been lots of people
chatting about stuff sending messages
making sure everyone's okay checking in
with each other you have to remember as
well you know Nottingham is a big
student City there are lots of people
that work in bars late at night that are
perhaps walking home getting an
e-scooter or a taxi so yeah I imagine
there's a lot of you know people that
are worried about their loved ones this
morning and you know hopefully
everything thing is okay it's just it's
just awful it really is awful what's the
atmosphere like there
well it it it's slightly it's slightly
tense in a way in a sense that it's just
the uncertainty of it all and not really
understanding what's happened and you
know I I feel like it's it's an it's a
neighborhood it's you know you chat to
your neighbors and you chat to your
friends you know you've got your
WhatsApp groups going off social media
you're seeing reports coming in and I
think it's just that that it's that
unrest it's we've never had anything
that I can remember certainly like this
happen in Nottingham it's a you know
it's a relatively small City and it just
feels like
everyone's been completely rattled and
devastated by these events and you know
my thoughts are with those affected is
it's just an awful situation
have you managed to speak to um any of
the um
Police Service or whatever what are they
saying to you
I I have been avoiding the area to be
honest I mean I only live as I say five
minutes from magdala Road um I've kind
of respected the police call in there
and I I've stayed away you know perhaps
as well just for safety reasons I just
thought I'd rather just stay in my house
um today but as I understand it that you
know the cordons are still in place
there are people in the city center
there are still people going into work
some of the shops are open in the main
shopping center so there are people
going about their their daily business
but of course a lot of the city center
still being massively affected by this